c'était la mauvaise surprise du week-end
pascal
après avoir différé la hausse du super
pendant un mois les pétroliers ont
finalement craqué vendredi dernier et
modifier leur compteur résultat des bons
de 20 centimes si l'on décortique cette
augmentation
on trouve un dollar fort avec en france
une augmentation en janvier de la taxe
sur les carburants
on trouve aussi la fin de la guerre iran
irak
les anciens belligérants besoin de prix
stables pour reconstruire leur économie
résultat le baril est remonté de 12 à 16
dollars
cela c'est la hausse actuelle et la
grande peur revient cette fois de
l'alaska pour cause de marée noire on a
fermé la semaine dernière des ports qui
écoulait le quart de la production
américaine
les prix ont flambé pourtant les experts
ne croient pas un nouveau choc pétrolier
une remontée brutale des prix je crois
que dans les deux trois ans à venir au
moins les prix continueront d'évoluer
dans une fourchette de 15 à 10 y est
parfois 18 dollar par baril au contraire
on pourrait assister en france à une
nouvelle guerre des prix entre grandes
surfaces et pétroliers d'un côté des
supermarchés qui assure 40 % de la
distribution
un chiffre unique au monde mais pas sûr
que les grandes surfaces trouve encore
du pétrole peu cher sur le marché libre
ce qui avait fait leur force pendant
trois ans en face des compagnies
pétrolières qui veulent regagner le
terrain perdu et ne peuvent donc pas
pousser les prix trop mais si guerre des
prix il ya elle ne jouera que sur
quelques centimes sur 5 30 super carte
francs vont à l'état il ne reste pas
grand chose pour faire jouer la
concurrence